oh [__]
your [__] have no idea what you
got yourself into today Friday November
2nd the day the devil was buried at sea
pilot the [__] Bombardier you
understand me because we're going deep
you better take your vitamins we're
gonna go deep with some 27% isn't above
this morning cuz that's how I roll you
understand me I'm not showing up in no
Susquehanna I'm friends with this guy I
read [__] high times who gives a [__]
in my world you gotta see the devil
7:24 if not it's not gonna work out for
you he understand he was showing up with
two guns today two guns
[__] 18 bullets [__] grenades the
whole thing you know why cuz that's how
we do it you understand me
we're here to play games at your
[__] and tell your lies and
tire you know oh yeah oh yeah
I know what's going on here it's like
getting up I'm the [__] cloud of
death but not really [__] it we'll have
to make it work you understand me uncle
Joey here getting cleared by the [__]
minute I missed you [__] all
week I've been busy doing this doing
that taking their beatings but number
one I want to thank you for staying
loyal to the [__] Church or what's
happening now and you're called Joey
number two I want to thank you for
watching the Netflix [__] special you
got to look under degenerates that's
when you look under when you're looking
on the front pull Joey understand me but
who gives a [__] about all that number
one was smoking this morning the triple
G Oh triple [__] xog from urban trees
it's that [__] 28.1% and then look at
this one we got this cake batter over
here from [__] it's 30 percent of
people you understand me so for you guys
that I love the sativa this is the one
right here if you love sativa and you
want to feel your [__] body levitate
like the chick from The Exorcist we
gotta face this thing here I don't like
these clouds maybe maybe it's [__]
All Souls Day and we got a bad
connection
[Music]
gives a [__] the message you get through
you understand me I don't know if I got
palm trees in front of me or maybe it's
just time to go get a new four
[__] iPhone you following me
there which one I might have to do today
so you could see the [__] Bell off a
hula thumbs at any one journey let's
park this [__] meal cause it's Friday
[__] and wave taking on
[__] prisoners you follow me
beside that both your churches up Eric
Rocha promoting the CD I already did it
great in some of the church when I tend
to support him thank you very much and
my mom bass Bruton don't forget I was on
Rogan this week we had the [__] I mean
we listened it was just one of those
weeks but guess what it's all because of
you guys I'm sincere enough and I have
the balls to say it's this is a [__]
collaboration we've come full circle
understand me
[__] tremendous look at this it's
like coming to you direct from a [__]
steam bath right now I blo that Joe
Rogan podcast [__] contest up with
that little heart meter right now but
who gives a [__]
maybe that's what it is I want to
congratulate the dudes that did so by
October just the point that they they
stuck not to [__] get down that's
what I tap out
listen I go for all the other shiny no
sugar I don't need nothing else but
that's what I need to smoke my reefa it
keeps my powder dry I chair I rock a
little safe by being at there getting my
might and morongo via book that me
seeking the wrong car bingo anyway Joey
enough with the [__] Spanish Sesame
Street and let's smoke some
[__] reefer here it's coming at
you from all directions I also have this
gorgeous right here this this cake
batter I told you about not to mention
the orange cookies this will put you in
a different [__] planet this is all
urban trees Ventura Boulevard tell them
I sent you to hook you up Thomas and I
want to see the devil like joy element I
want to have that [__] paradise
coming out of the top of my forehead
this is the one that got in this Tammy
and that's it and that's that I just
wanted to touch base for you
let you know I didn't forget
[__] never Luca there's your
[__] family I'm with you you're with
me and these [__] want to be with us
that's why they're pissed because they
ain't got the [__] balls to Rumbles
[__] this kebab stick plane to leaving
Burbank uncle Joey just ripped a
tremendous [__] [__] and that's it
lift a little jujitsu I got a meeting
that is date night with the wife I'm
gonna watch the Queen movie maybe get a
bite to eat and that's it and that's
that
listen New York is sold out for shows
you got one option left New York City
and that's like Friday early and you
better jump on it cuz I haven't even
done radio yet [__] so New York
next weekend chance dragon and Rudy's
and clothes side part my mother and Jedi
over there by Hudson County some [__]
Cuban food in Edgewater and I'm good to
go you understand me the mule it's on
its way to [__] New Jersey as we
speak it should be touching down on
Monday I got in there [__] Thursday
and it's all over but the shouting you
follow me
but hey what's with the chitter chatter
Joey let's smoke some more refresh what
I say what the [__] you only live once
right
let's smoke some of this to two loops
right here
and see what else we got going on it was
like I said as I smoke I think of more
things I got a head onto the [__]
list of the day you follow me remember
you could always be doing something when
you're sitting on the couch watching
some [__] do talk about whatever I
think I'm gonna do it you heading I'm
gonna do it you but it's got to do it
it's what you could be doing the [__]
pick up an envelope
cuz the envelope should always be in the
back of your mind yeah I'm looking at
anything and that money reads for
cocaine chlamydia I don't give a [__]
what you pick up in the envelopes
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive you understand me grab your ball
salute the flag and give Jesus some
[__] love to giving you another day
cause that's the most important thing
that you have another day to [__] let
these [__] know you ain't
[__] around no more and that's it and
that's that getting ready for UFC
[__] whatever tomorrow
put on your bucks on [__] brutal
because you know whatever the Beast
what do you got my loose I lose that's
it put all this down and go to bed if he
knocks on Mike because he's already
talking to my buck last and that's no
bueno and they told my blessing you
haven't even fought Derek the Beast what
if Derek what the Popeyes and had 80
pieces that have [__] poisoned
chicken you ever go to Popeyes last
moment the Popeyes in Hollywood if
somebody's [__] foot inside the
breast when I took the skin off
I could see the four towers I don't know
over there while a black that's not for
me to decide my point is he's eating
that Popeyes Chicken you'll kill the
[__] after that that [__] about
me your system you start hating life you
must wait fifty [__] Vikings look at
me I'm performing from the mouth that's
how good this reefer is
but enough is enough
you got the message you know I love you
[__] if you got nothing to do
don't forget to watch the degenerates
and that's it brother is it my best work
is it my whatever listen all you need to
know is there's more to come you come
see me live I'll blow your [__]
titties off you understand me your
wife's ring and have [__] eyebrows
will [__] disintegrate
that's the kind of heat I'm throwing
these days so you make the [__]
choice I love your [__] with
all my heart thank you thank you for
always being there for me and for having
my back but I you [__] I have
nothing the week is up to you listen
this weekend out of battery they're all
over cuz you're coming out Monday like a
[__] the kid that's been in there for
[__] ten months you're shooting that
you're spitting at the doctor's face and
you tell them to suck your dick and for
my Spanish people or you did you think
about my tell her beating up a business
out there mething I said to when I walk
I imagine I'm a Ronda that's the way it
is I love your [__] stay black
enjoy the Netflix special enjoy the
podcast I'll see you guys next week
maybe another Awards day nice and early
no drum